explique à son chef fraîchement élu le
déroulement avant la période de
questions
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon était motif
devant les caméras qui attendent de le
voir essayer d'entrer au Salon bleu
jouer l'arsenault regarde sa montre
c'est plutôt long les travaux débutent
en retard ce matin les obligeant à faire
le pied de grue tous les autres élus
dument assermenté se rejoignent dans le
salon bleu moi je pense que
cette travailler aidé les Québécois à
faire face à l'inflation si pour le
Parti québécois il y a d'autres
priorités
le geste médiatisé du PQ ça m'a pas fait
particulièrement plaisir de prêter
serment au roi moi non plus mais on le
fait pour pouvoir siéger pour pouvoir
débattre pour que je puisse aujourd'hui
poser des questions en matière de santé
c'est à ce moment-là nous qu'on a fini
par décider de se boucher le nez puis
d'aller prêter serment
je pense que c'est un geste qui a une
signification une portée historique tous
les médias veulent voir ce que fera la
sergent d'armes
donc exactement la nouvelle présidente
Nathalie Roy maintient la décision de
son prédécesseur la Constitution exige
un serment au roi pour siège cette
décision est finale et sans appel et ne
peut être mise en question Paul
saint-pierre-plamondon n'a d'autre choix
que de tourner les talons puis on fait
avancer les choses en l'espace d'une
semaine seulement on a réussi à rallier
toutes les partis politiques pour que ça
change hier le Parti libéral du Québec
Freddy qui voulait que ça change à
l'intérieur les pékistes ont brillé par
leur absence Québec Solidaire a déposé
ce matin son projet de loi pour abolir
le serment au roi le gouvernement
déposera le sien la semaine prochaine
mais seront-ils vraiment pressés de
l'adopter et faire entrer plus vite
leurs adversaires au Salon bleu ici
Véronique prince Radio-Canada Québec